christine villemin écroué à la prison de
metz a entamé une grève de la faim pour
protester contre son inculpation vous
voyez des images hier au moment de cette
inculpation de l'arrestation plus tôt
son avocat maître garraud indiqué qu'il
l'avait trouvé très abattu et qu'elle
avait qu'il avait tenté de la convaincre
de s'alimenter dans les jours qui
avaient précédé son arrestation et son
inculpation pour l'assassinât du petit
grégory christine villemin avait déclaré
que le juge lambert s'il la mettait aux
prises au la part d'ombré sa mort sur la
conscience des propos qu'elle avait
répété la semaine dernière chez nos
confrères d'europe 1 au micro de jean
pierre elkabbach
je sais ce que j'ai fait j'ai pas fait
de mal je vois pas pourquoi j'irais en
prison je suivrai pas si je suis resté
un mois ou deux ans en prison je crois
que je ressortirai met les pieds devant
puisque je crois que je vais mais c'est
le nourrir blanchissant rien à faire je
ferai la grève de la faim je veux pas
mais sa cuisine ce que je n'ai pas
refait